certain Norm that oh he probably has
about 30 bodies right he probably has
about 40 bodies men now have about 50
bodies men now have about 60 bodies you
know what that sounds like a bunch of
men being honest about approximate
numbers okay women are putting
themselves in a box if every woman out
here told me that they had 20 bodies 20
bodies wouldn't be a lot to me okay but
when you all are not incohesive uh in a
cohesive team and some of you are
telling me three and some of you are
telling me 25 who you think I'm rocking
with I agree so now what I'm trying to
say is women need to go ahead and tell
all you women out there need to go ahead
and get in your little Collective
circles and be like yo we're gonna be
honest how many you got how many you got
you got 15 I got 19. you got 22. all
right we gonna stick with 20. this is
the new number you got to understand
what the Norms are and the norm is if if
every single women in America
told every man they had 20 bodies I
guarantee you 20 wouldn't be a lot I
agree with you I we had this
conversation earlier and the
conversation was based around
and Al and I were discussing I said the
reality is for me like if a woman says
I've slept with x amount of people and I
you know it's something that I enjoyed I
did it whatever but whenever somebody
tries to hide something tries to like
not show it that that it almost brings
an energy with it so you see her and she
has that energy I don't I don't know if
it's shame or guilt or whatever it is so
if women took ownership and I agree with
you Rico rather than thinking that hey
we're worried about what men are going
to say own what you did but that's what
I'm trying I didn't even get to finish
right sorry I didn't get to finish
because I was long-winded but I was
saying all that to tie into my good
friend Pearl's point
okay
women judge women more than men judge
women I don't so I'm not saying you
specifically I'm just saying in totality
in general women destroy women more than
men destroy women and women judge women
more than men judge women right so and
and women give other women less Shake
than women than men right women also
listen to women more than they listen to
men this is a women like women have a
whole community that they go like this
and it doesn't matter they stick with
each other through thick and thin and I
think it's a beautiful thing but now the
problem that happens is
women can be real with their friends I
know girls who has smashed me and lied
to her friends and then their friends
tried to tell me I was lying that I
smashed and I was like well guess what I
I'm not gonna show you the proof but I
got it you know what I'm saying so now
what it comes down to is not a a woman
being honest with men thing it's a woman
being honest with I'm not even gonna say
they're friends and their other women
being honest with themselves most women
are not happy having sex with a lot of
men
so when they're having sex with a lot of
men what are they gonna do lie about it
because they're ashamed that they're
even doing it if you wasn't ashamed of
doing it you would be over here
clapping and embracing your actions
you know what I'm saying like if I go
ahead and I win an Oscar award
I'm gonna be proud of it I'm going to
I'm going to chant my oscar it wouldn't
matter if anyone said to him like oh
that's you're an Oscar [ __ ] you're an
Oscar [ __ ] like you wouldn't
out of it yeah it doesn't matter even
when I say hey look I got a lot of
bodies girl you think girls don't girls
don't DM me and comment and say you're a
hoe you think that never happened to me
it's been happening to me since I was in
high school you know what I said all
right so what's next what I do I'm
comfortable doing it of course because
this is who I am but but the patriarchal
system no it is to be more comfortable
no it's not more comfortable it's that
people do people do things that they
think people say for example I'm not
ashamed Rico like the thing is Richard
was having an interesting conversation
about it like if you come out and you
say hey I have slept with
a thousand women right maybe some people
who
yeah like there's a lot of women
you know like for me I'd be like yo
that's crazy right yeah but like most
people or most men aren't going to be
like my God that's so disgusting you
however what do you mean that's false
that's false my one of my boss you said
you slept with a thousand women opposed
to a woman saying she slept with a
thousand men and we reviewed the comment
section like they would come for her
because in terms of expectations like
you think women don't come for me if I
say one thing remotely close to the
guy's Edge I'm a narcissist and a
misogynist so so I don't want to hear
that comment section and I said women
come giving a small I'm just sentence
with Instagram and pull this up man are
shamed more than women are for
everything men are trash like you even
we have little things like men are
idiots men are dumb men aren't as smart
yeah it's even though I think that you
guys are like you're generalizing
something that doesn't I've never called
somebody a hoe a [ __ ] or whatever when
I see my daughter's timeline and
somebody say hey [ __ ] I said you better
take that [ __ ] down yeah because we
don't do that and it's like you're
shaming like if my friend told me oh my
God I have sex with this guy and this is
I'm not going to be like oh my God
you're a [ __ ] you thinking it no I'm
not no I'm not because this I think it's
a difference it's like I would be like
why would you do that like didn't you
know what I'm saying
yeah I didn't call you a b word I just
said you're acting like one you know how
many women went on vacations and didn't
come back friends no they test the
sorority houses how much drama is in
sorority houses
eternity houses and sorority houses
fraternity Brothers they're brothers for
life sorority sisters they talk [ __ ]
about each other for Life what is the
age audience
don't point the camera on me Alan
yeah when you guys say this no I don't
listen
attack on women like what what is the
goal I just want to know like if we're
really trying to help society and we're
really trying if you are trying to help
society and you're trying to think
excited I don't know but what's the
solution how do like I don't know I
actually okay I don't either you I don't
like this combative attack on women all
right we're gonna we're gonna go ahead
and ask me a question oh I do I want an
answer I don't think it's an attack on
women to speak General truths and it's
it's interesting because in this
conversation whenever we say like a
general truth like it seems like you
guys fight it and I feel like you guys
know what we're talking about on on an
innate level but like you pretend you
don't so I think you know that women are
cattier than men you just like are
pretending it's an attack just just my
perception I don't know you personally
no offense and it's so second Solutions
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible